un acuerdo ambicioso el presidente iraní
ebrahim raisi y su homólogo venezolano
nicolás maduro fueron testigos de la
firma del plan de cooperación por 20
años entre ambas naciones ricas en
petróleo y enfrentadas con washington
de la firma de un documento de
cooperación de 20 años entre los dos
países muestra la determinación de los
funcionarios de alto nivel para el
desarrollo de las relaciones en
diferentes campos
además el petróleo del acuerdo detalla
la cooperación bilateral en sectores
como la petroquímica la defensa la
agricultura el turismo y la cultura
también se acordó la reparación iraní de
refinerías venezolanas y la exportación
de servicios técnicos y de ingeniería
así como el inicio de un vuelo semanal
de caracas a teherán para promover el
incipiente turismo ha llevado a este año
en mejores condiciones más preparados y
más fuertes
articular la fuerza de irán y venezuela
en un mapa de cooperación verdaderamente
asombroso irán junto a rusia china cuba
y turquía son aliados importantes para
venezuela ambas naciones cooperan desde
2020 en proyectos energéticos e
intercambios de petróleo irán y
venezuela no solo están unidos por el
petróleo ambas naciones están sometidas
a fuertes sanciones de parte de eeuu
pero la invasión rusa en ucrania y la
necesidad de petróleo tiene a washington
reconsiderando las sanciones con el país
de nicolás maduro
[Música]